bon voila voila il y à des milliers
d'associations france qui organise et
spectacles et ronan parler fort
aujourd'hui
oui alors vous pouvez faire du collage
s'il vous plaît pouvez-vous une fois
faire la quête pour un tournoi et non
écoutez monsieur algues se vendent sur
toutes les chaussures ce qu'on peut
acheter par les votes du public s'il
vous plaît patrice blanc francard n'a
pas pas placer un mot ce soir avec lui
conclut non mais maintenant mon enfance
en effet s'il vous plaît on attend sur
son nom mais je recueille la peut-être
gaultier lauriau vous n'avez parlé que
du 10e regret les building r non je
savais qu'elle était pas moins de
bonheur mais alors il faut maintenant je
voudrais halimi et 10 heures on peut
dire quelque chose
y aller si vous faudrait signaler que
sur ce plateau ce soir sont venues des
invités qui ont chacun le droit d'amener
un invité qui ce thème est assis dans le
fond de la salle j'aurais voulu que ces
gens respectent un peu l'émission
autrement nous inviterons plus les gens
que sur l'émission mais ça ça m'est égal
vous aimerez ce métier pas du moment
vous vous taisez voilà alors je voudrais
quand même pas je savais que madame
molinier qui est venu là soir elle va
finir par le regretter
parce que non mais je vous préviens je
n'ai pas de chance
on a réalisé ce qu'on dit à chaque
émission alors si l'organe suprême voilà
c'est ce qu'on dit à chaque échange et
moi on pourrait peut-être dire des
choses concrètes machine attention au
tableau le fond du fond dans le showbiz
mal et on le sort ce monsieur alors nous
allons essayer on va faire venir je
regrette que les coudes et agissent et
berne et des éleveurs
et je vais vous faire écouter chance
aujourd'hui c'est assume cette fonction
des changements de voiles à regarder
l'accord laissez-le l'a envoyé générique
de fin et qu'on paie l'image parce que
c'est vraiment pas plaisant
- mettez le le générique de fin avec la
chanson de dia colombo voilà mettez la
chanson de biakolo nuls et l'antenne en
comp l'antenne et je m'exclus nouvelle
et téléspectateurs soit kim
or et plaisant